hace siete años sin fold y se convirtió
en el primer periodista estadounidense
en ser ejecutado por el grupo estado
islámico su decapitación filmada y su
vida en línea conmocionó al mundo para
la madre de folk y jim murió por los
valores que apreciaba
quién murió por lo que pensó que era la
verdad por lo que sintió que era
importante sintió que era un trabajo que
debía hacerse estaba soltero sentía que
podía hacerlo le encantó le encantó
escuchar lo que estaba pasando y luego
escribir la historia capturando las
imágenes para traer de vuelta al mundo
michaels
tres semanas después de la muerte de jim
ryan foley creó una fundación pidiendo
al gobierno de eeuu que hiciera más para
liberar a los rehenes reporteros o no
cada vez es más peligroso ser periodista
ya sea en este país o en todo el mundo y
creo que esto se debe principalmente a
que hay mucha desinformación ahora que
hace más difícil que la verdad salga a
la luz
a menos que se responsabiliza a las
personas que atacan matan y torturan a
los periodistas
de la isla al arian ha convertido en una
prioridad proteger a sus reporteros
después de 20 años de informar en
entornos hostiles ahora es ella quien
envía a los periodistas a los sitios de
peligro con protocolos de seguridad pues
tratamos de averiguar todo lo posible
sobre el sitio al que vamos en lugar de
simplemente lanzarnos en paracaídas y no
darnos cuenta atacados encarcelados o
asesinados la violencia en contra de los
periodistas ha aumentado en todo el
mundo en los últimos 30 años más de 1400
han sido asesinados y los perpetradores
rara vez comparecen ante la justicia